This is one of the best ads that I've
ever seen. So, it's a Timex ad and it
says, "Know the time without seeing that
you have 1,249
unanswered emails." So, the formula
behind the headline of this ad is a
super classic formula and it is benefit
without pain. Know the time is the
benefit without seeing that you have
1,249
unread emails is the pain. It's a pain
targeted at people like the smartwatch
industry. People get anxiety from seeing
all those emails. So, it's a huge pain.
And the kicker to this headline formula
benefit without pain is definitely the
pain. So, if you write a headline, the
bigger the pain that your product
solves, the better the headline. So
steal that headline formula next time
you want to write a killer